i believe that learning about fitness
should mean more than understanding the
top five
exercises you can do for great abs
learning more about ourselves allows us
to make smarter choices with regards to
training and nutrition
and it may provide useful self knowledge
and insight all type of knowledge
ultimately means self knowledge and to
really learn about yourself
you need to get down to the fundamentals
in this case
that means the genetic level so dna is
the most efficient form of data storage
known to man a single gram is capable of
storing 215 petabytes of information
that's 215 million gigabytes
there are about 3 billion units of
information stored across the combined
dna sequence
and a gene is a stretch of dna that
encodes for a specific function or trait
and there are around 30 000 of these
genes in the human genome
this information is separated into 46
chromosomes located
in turn inside the nuclei centers of the
cells chromosomes mostly exist in pairs
with one from each parent there are 23
pairs although the 23rd pair are the sex
chromosomes
x and y while the chromosome pairs
contain near identical sequences they
each include
differences alleles inherited from the
respective parent
each strand of dna is made up of
nucleotides that sit like beads on a
thread
nucleotides are comprised of three
components a sugar molecule
a phosphate group and a nitrogenous base
these are called nucleobases or just
bases
these bases come in four possible
flavors adenine cytosine
guanine and thymine a c g and t
these form base pairs with complementary
bases on the other strand which is what
gives dna its helical structure that we
know and love
so the main job of dna is to build
proteins in other words to create the
building blocks that form our tissues
to do this dna is transferred to
messenger molecules called
mrna in a process known as transcription
in short your dna determines the amounts
and the locations of different proteins
within the body
determining how your cells behave and
ultimately resulting in the individual
differences
phenotypes that make you you
because most of our genetic code is
identical among all humans we can focus
only on those areas that show
significant amount of variation
within the population these changeable
positions are called
snps single nucleotide polymorphisms
they're pronounced snips because someone
was being cute i guess
these are variations affecting only one
nucleotide meaning a cytosine
might be replaced with a thymine for
example a polymorphism
is a variation that affects over one
percent of the population
because we have two pairs of each gene
we then have to look at the
corresponding chromosome
to see if the same variation exists
there those that inherit two copies of
the same base
ie gg are described as being homozygous
those with just one copy are
heterozygous
in such cases it will be the dominant
gene that is expressed
or the genes will interact in some way
there are countless studies identifying
specific snips and showing how they
correlate with particular traits
an allyl is a version of a gene that has
a particular effect
you might have the brown eyes allele for
example although it's not that simple in
reality
mutation it is the key to our evolution
it has enabled us to evolve from a
single-celled organism into the dominant
species on the planet
genetic mutations are different a
mutation is a change of the dna sequence
that is considered abnormal or extremely
rare
a deviation from the norm beneficial
mutations are rare by definition
as those changes that are successful are
likely to make their way into the
general population
the most famous mutation as it pertains
to athletic performance affects the
myostatin
mstn gene animals and extremely rare
humans even
with a premature stop codeine exhibit a
myostatin deficiency
as myostatin is known to inhibit muscle
growth this can in turn
lead to double muscling which is as cool
as it sounds
the result is superior muscle strength
and size along with increased running
speed in whippet dogs
however it might also be associated with
an increased risk of tendon injuries
most mutations are harmful however which
is why we're actually more interested in
the slightly less exotic polymorphisms
and in short it means you're very
unlikely to be an x-man sorry
but this is where things get really
interesting because certain
polymorphisms have been shown to
correlate with different traits
and in particular athletic and cognitive
traits this is not to say that someone
with that gene is likely going to be a
super athlete
however nor does it mean that you can't
become a super athlete without that gene
to say that a single gene let alone a
single nucleotide
can determine your performance in any
given area is a drastic overreach
for example you might have a tendency
towards fast twitch muscle fiber which
is great
but if you produce low testosterone or
if you have unhelpful tendon insertions
or tricky hip socket or if you have
issues with motor learning
any of those things might prevent you
from being an effective weight lifter
the predictions themselves are based on
just a handful of studies in most cases
only a fraction of the four to five
million snips in the human genome
have been studied at all all a report
like this can say is
looking at the studies there appears to
be a correlation between genotype a and
result b
and of course environment and training
have huge roles to play in how genes are
expressed
and what we actually experience in fact
i've heard it said that the most gifted
natural athletes sometimes lack
sufficient drive
owing to the fact that everything has
always come easy for them until they
reach those really elite stages
and this is where a little self
knowledge can be extremely valuable
because if you know which of your own
polymorphisms are negatively affecting
your performance
you can look into ways to mitigate them
with smart training
you could potentially outperform even
the best of the best
so the question remains which snips are
known to predict superior athletic and
cognitive
performance here are just a few
interesting ones
ac tn3 actn3
is perhaps the most talked about gene
when it comes to athletic performance
especially as it relates to explosive
strength the act n3 gene
also called the speed gene encodes the
protein actinin alpha 3
which is a sarcomeric protein related to
the formation of fast twitch muscle
fiber
recovery and training adaptation ac tn3
is expressed preferentially in the
fastest
type 2x fibers the ideal genotype
controlled by the polymorphism
r577x rs1815739
can therefore allow an individual to
build more explosive muscle
more easily whereas conversely roughly
18
of the population is completely
deficient in acting in alpha 3.
it is swings and roundabouts though as
these guys tend to perform better in
endurance tasks
ace another gene that gets a lot of
attention is the angiotensin one
converting enzyme gene or ace to its
friends
ace can encourage the formation of a
vasoconstrictor blood vessel narrowing
agent
called ang2 while also degrading the
vasodilator
bradykinin ang2 is also a recognized
growth factor in its own right
and contributes to hypertrophy the ace
gene insertion deletion polymorphism
is associated with improved exercise
performance and duration
in particular the insertion allele has
been shown to correlate with improved
endurance related activity the deletion
alol meanwhile
is related to improved strength and
power based performance
and is regularly found among elite level
swimmers
this d allele is also related to greater
heart response to training
in the left ventricle
il-6 interleukin-6 is a pleiotropic
cytokine
that also plays a role in fibrogenesis
and the expression of vascular
endothelial growth factor
or vegf il-6 is produced by the muscles
in response to exercise
and aids in recovery aiding in
neutrophil mobilization
and promoting impaired insulin
resistance is even referred to by some
scientists
as an exercise factor what's really
interesting is that il-6
appears to be particularly useful when
engaging in eccentric training
i listed a few more of these on my
website so if you'd like to see more
potential polymorphisms that might
affect your athletic performance
go and check those out
as well as increased speed strength and
stamina winning the genetic lottery can
also potentially gift an individual
with improved cognition for instance the
rs-6265 polymorphism
affects the bdnf gene this is
brain-derived neurotrophic factor
a chemical that promotes the growth of
new neurons and synapses
the cll of this particular snp is linked
with better n-back scores and working
memory
larger amounts of slow wave sleep which
is possibly linked with greater neural
plasticity
and possibly even higher mean
intelligence
genes influence personality in countless
ways too one of the most interesting
genes in this regard is
com t comt which is referred to as the
warrior warrior gene the snip rfs-4680
is linked to our ability to break down
catecholamine neurotransmitters
such as norepinephrine cortisol and
dopamine
thus comt activity can influence how
quickly an individual is able to recover
from stressful events
but of course this is again contingent
on the initial levels of those
neurotransmitters
among countless other factors not to
mention life experience
there have been several studies that
link specific snips to overall success
in education and career paths even
but i should take this opportunity to
point out that this doesn't mean we
should judge a person's potential
success
on their genetics nor is any genotype
objectively better than any other
the future's not set there's no fit but
what we make for ourselves
apart from anything else these findings
are more reflective of the traits that
society happens to value at any given
time
rather than the innate gifts or
shortcomings in the population
school systems in particular are
notoriously bad at predicting future
greatness
examples of forthcoming of those that
dropped out of school only to later be
considered geniuses within their fields
our measures of fluid intelligence are
also far from perfect and of course
there are countless environmental
factors that can predict overall success
in fact it's our differences that really
enable us to provide real value
my favorite blogs to read are the ones
that have something unique and different
to say
a different perspective the best music
is new and interesting music that you
haven't heard before
and of course lifestyle and training
also play a huge role
depending on your starting hand you
might just be able to train your way
out of any perceived shortcomings gene
expression is controlled by methylation
a process in which chemicals called
methyl groups attach themselves to dna
and thus block specific portions
from being active throughout your cells
different genes are expressed
resulting in the production of different
proteins this is how a muscle cell can
behave differently from a brain cell for
instance
despite containing the same dna if you
imagine that dna contains the alphabet
methylation allows the body to spell out
certain words by crossing out letters
this is epigenetics what's cool about
this is that training diet and lifestyle
factors
all contribute to gene expression and
methylation
the moment we begin working out the
activity of genes within muscle cells
gets altered
something similar occurs in the brain
following a bout of learning diet is
similarly
impactful as is everything from stress
to sunlight to sleep
and much more interestingly gene
expression itself can also be increased
or decreased
through diet and other methods and may
itself be more or less mutable
depending on your initial genotype
and what's really cool is the epigenetic
changes can actually stick around
and even be passed on to offspring your
training or lack thereof can therefore
have a direct impact on the athleticism
of your future children something to
consider
so if anything i hope that all of this
just serves to show how truly complex we
humans are
every one of your traits is the result
of countless contributing factors
both genetic and environmental i've
barely scratched the surface and there's
so much here that we rarely hear in the
conversation surrounding muscle building
or athletic performance we're so
different that we should be very careful
giving generalized advice to any person
a supplement or neurotropic that helps
one person may be ineffective or even
harmful for someone else
we also see why different people respond
better or worse to particular types of
training
the key is to keep looking until you
find what works for you
i believe that we all have something
unique to offer and our success really
comes down to our ability to express
that uniqueness
in a way that is genuine and that offers
value if you found all of this
interesting and you'd like to learn more
about your own dna
and how it might impact your performance
then i highly recommend checking out
selfdecode.com i've put a link to that
in the description down below
and this isn't a sponsored post but i
will earn a little bit of commission if
you follow that and decide to make a
purchase
so that would support the site in a big
way and i'd be very grateful indeed
essentially self-decode analyzes your
dna and then gives you extremely
detailed reports
along with other stuff relating to your
health fitness cognition stress levels
and much more
you can even find out how susceptible
you might be to covert they detail how
everything works in a comprehensive
manner provide links to all the studies
and even provide actionable tips you can
follow
if you do decide you want to give it a
try you can either order a testing kit
which requires you to send back some
saliva
or you can just upload a file you
already have if you've done that before
for sites like ancestry
this is an exciting new frontier for
fitness and coaching but it needs to be
used in the right way
of course there are other sites that do
similar things so shop around as well if
you like
anyway i hope you found this video
useful and interesting i got a bit
technical on this one
if you did please consider leaving a
like and sharing it around as that would
help me out
immensely what do you think some of your
own genetic strengths and weaknesses are
and how have you adapted your training
in kind
if you like the idea of training in a
way that develops every aspect of your
fitness
including mobility strength speed
endurance and even cognitive performance
then you could check out my ebook and
training program super functional
training
there's a link to that in the
description down below as well and
there's a discount on whilst we're all
in lockdown
hit subscribe if you want more like this
and the bell button if you want to be
notified of new uploads
i'll be uploading the doom slayer
workout very soon as that's
by far my most requested video at the
moment so subscribe if you don't want to
miss that one
and either way thank you so much for
watching this one and for all your
support
and bye for now
you